[Music]
eyes looking so handsome
it is BTS mania at the American Music
Awards fans lined up look at the cameras
behind you how are you guys feeling it's
great good
tell me about performing tonight it's an
honor you feel excited hold a football
Sun and go we're going to pop home the
MA
yeah it's gonna be a history I think you
guys are all together but you didn't
bring your girlfriends no are you
looking we got armies we got like
thousands of girlfriends today in here
and Mike Ross selfie arena so we don't
worry no need to worry
I mean tell me about arriving in America
at LAX and the fans when you stepped off
the plane so we never expected like so
much fans in the airport belong to one
city like there were some photos of us
and he's like pigs like yes it was so
nice what do you think about kids not
going to school so they can see you play
oh oh oh that's all we bought we're
animal porn too
Sam what watch TV police I'm sorry but
we're living in 2017 you can watching
YouTube maybe later haha
who is most likely to be a heartbreaker
what do me a heartbreaker like like what
are you me a heart heart like I love you
bye towba came up a totally bad boy a
bad boy bad boy bad boy bad boy who is
most likely to get married first
who is most likely to start a dance
party hi doc what's up
[Music]
[Applause]
who is most likely to be late for
rehearsal
you got he also take this bus with you
on a three yeah me just me yeah yeah who
is most likely to mess up the
choreography to mess make a mistake okay
- so there are my members oh yeah bad
boy Wow okay who's most likely to cause
an argument
yeah to fight Solomon get my hypothesis
one two three
Wow I like peas
I like the pigeons my favorite bar is
pigeon so how did you pick your outfit
your fashion for tonight
oh it's basically all sing lawns so we
got you know what's important today so I
like your offensive shiny last thing
said after our interview on
Entertainment Tonight went live zed said
he wants to collaborate with you would
you guys want to collaborate was that
sad uncle Hubbins
[Applause]
you